BEING ASKED TO EXPLAIN THEIR
REALLY -- I MEAN, HONESTLY,
JAKE, I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
I'VE BEEN COMING DOWN HERE FOR
YEARS.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS.
AND IT'S NOT, AS I WAS SAYING IN
THE PRESS CONFERENCE, I'M USED
TO LIES, I'M USED TO HYPOCRISY,
I'M USED TO THEIR COWARDICE, I'M
NOT USED TO THE CRUELTY, THE
CASUAL CRUELTY OF PASSING A BILL
THEY HAD FOUGHT FOR, FOR MORE
THAN A DECADE.
AND LOOK, THERE ARE VIETNAM
VETERANS ON THIS BILL.
THEY'VE BEEN FIGHTING SINCE THE
'60s AND '70s, PEOPLE THAT
FOUGHT FOR US, PEOPLE THAT SAY
WE SUPPORT THE TRUTH.
TO PASS THAT BILL FOR THEM, TO
GIVE THEM THAT MOMENT OF
EXHALE -- BY THE WAY, THEIR
TRIAL ISN'T OVER.
THAT JUST MEANS THEIR FAMILY
WILL GET THE BENEFITS, THEY
MIGHT WON'T HAVE TO DECIDE
BETWEEN CHEMO AND THEIR CAR.
A LOT OF THESE GUYS, THEY TELL
ME THEY LIVE SCAN-TO-SCAN.
THEY LIVE IN THREE-MONTH
INCREMENTS.
THESE GUYS ARE, DON'T WORRY,
THIS IS PROCEDURAL.
IT'S A PROTEST AGAINST AN
AMENDMENT.
IT'S MANDATORY VERSUS
DISCRETIONARY.
IT'S ALL OF THESE NONSENSICAL
REASONS TO DELAY AND DENY, WHEN
THEY PASSED THE EXACT SAME BILL
ON JUNE 16th.
NOTHING'S CHANGED.
>> SO PAT TOOMEY, THE REPUBLICAN
FROM PENNSYLVANIA, HE SAYS IT'S
HIS AMENDMENT.
>> IT SHOULD SAY PATRIOT PAT
TOOMEY.
THAT'S HIS GIVEN MONIKER.
>> SO HIS AMENDMENT IS THE ONE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, THIS IS ALL
HELD UP OVER HE SAYS -- HIS
AMENDMENT ADDRESSES HOW THIS
$400 BILLION CAN BE SPENT.
HE SAYS AS IT'S UNRELATED, THE
MONEY CAN BE USED FOR THINGS NOT
FOR VETERANS.
>> THAT'S NONSENSE.
THE V.A. SECRETARY STILL HAS TO
GO IN EVERY YEAR AND EXPLAIN THE
APPROPRIATION AND THE USE.
AND THE SPENDING OF THE MONEY IS
RELATED TO THE BILL.
IT'S NOT A SLUSH FUND.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
SLUSH FUNDS, IF SENATOR TOOMEY
WANTS TO EXPLAIN HIS FISCAL
CONSERVATISM, WHY IT IS THAT HE
VOTED, YOU KNOW, EVERY YEAR WE
VOTE FOR WHAT'S CALLED THE OCO,
A $70 BILLION FUND THAT GOES ON
TOP OF THE $600 BILLION OR $700
BILLION THAT THE PENTAGON
ALREADY GETS.
AND IT'S UNACCOUNTABLE.
THERE ARE NO GUARD RAILS.
IT TRULY CAN BE SPENT ON PRETTY
MUCH WHATEVER THEY WANT TO SPEND
IT ON IT.
TOOMEY'S NEVER RAISED A PEEP
ABOUT IT.
NEVER RAISED HIS HAND.
HE'S NEVER OBJECTED.
HE'S NEVER HELD UP THE DEFENSE
BILL BECAUSE OF IT.
AND THE FUND IS THE HIT RAL
DEFINITION OF A SLUSH FUND.
ALL OF THESE INDIVIDUALS THAT
VOTED TO DENY THE VETERANS AND
THE HEALTH CARE THEY'VE BEEN
FIGHTING FOR, FOR 15 YEARS,
VOTED FOR THIS SLUSH FUND.
SO THEY'RE LYING.
A, YOU CAN'T JUST SPEND THIS
MONEY ON WHATEVER YOU WANT TO.
AND B, WHEN THERE HAVE BEEN
BILLIONS IN EX-PENDABLE MONEY
THAT THEY CAN SPEND WHATEVER
THEY WANT TO, THEY VOTE FOR IT.
>> THE CONGRESSWOMAN SLOTKIN,
WHEN I ASKED HER ABOUT THIS, SHE
SAID, IT'S ODD HOW NOBODY HAS
ANY OBJECTION AND HOW MUCH MONEY
WE SPEND ON GOING TO WAR.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO TAKING CARE
OF THE PEOPLE WHO WAGE THESE
WARS --
>> TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
RICK SCOTT, SENATOR, SAID GLAD
TO BE HERE AT THE VSO TO HONOR
THEIR SERVICE.
AND THEN AN HOUR LATER WENT ON
THE FLOOR AND DENIED THOSE
VETERANS HEALTH CARE AND
BENEFITS.
LIKE, THE HYPOCRISY IS SO
GALLING.
BUT THEN YOU GET TO A PLACE
WHERE I'M AT RIGHT NOW, WHICH IS
HOW DO YOU SHAME THE SHAMELESS?
WHAT WILL GET THROUGH TO THEM
THE STORIES THAT YOU HEARD ARE
HEARTBREAKING.
A GENTLEMAN TOLD ME OF SOMEONE
WHO COMMITTED SUICIDE, ROSY'S
HUSBAND ATTEMPTED TO TAKE HIS
OWN LIFE BASED ON HIS
DESPERATION WITH THIS SYSTEM AND
PROCESS OF BEING DENIED CARE.
AND THESE GUYS, THEY ACT LIKE
OH, DON'T WORRY.
MAYBE WE'LL GET TO IT NOW OR IN
THE LAME DUCK SESSION.
SOME OF THESE FOLKS WON'T BE
AROUND.
THEY LIVE SCAN TO SCAN.
SO THEY CAN PRETEND TO BE ON
SENATE TIME, BUT THESE OTHER
FOLKS ARE ON HUMAN TIME.
AND THAT TIME IS PRECIOUS.
YOU KNOW, SENATE TIME, THESE
GUYS ALL LIVE TO BE 200 YEARS
OLD.
THEY NEVER LOSE THEIR JOBS,
ALWAYS GET THEIR HEALTH CARE.
NOTHING MATTERS